hey everyone I'm Abby sharp from Abby's
kitchen back with round 2 and my
nutrition mythbusters' because trust me
there is no shortage of bogus
misinformation out there when it comes
to eating well so in today's video I'm
back with two more of the most popular
myths that I'm gonna debug' juice
cleanses are the best way to kickstart
your weight loss BAM this right here is
a really well crafted marketing ploy the
juice or cleanse or detox world has
recently exploded leading you to believe
that your journey to weight loss is as
simple as a green juice away now don't
get me wrong guys I love myself a good
cold-pressed juice but thinking this is
the cure-all after a week-long poutine
bender
not so much all of these juice programs
and restrictive diets are based on the
assumption that your body needs to be
cleansed of its toxins but in reality
your liver and kidneys and intestines
have been doing a pretty damn good job
of this for centuries and we don't need
to pay them anything for it and yes some
people have lost a lot of weight on
these juice cleanses but that's because
they're mainly just water some
carbohydrates and really low in calories
meanwhile they are often devoid of
protein which is essential for muscle
maintenance and can be so low in
calories they can actually slow your
metabolism down guess what happens when
you go back to eating normally again
folks yeah you're probably gonna gain
that weight right back and if you've
been doing it long enough and you've
maybe lost some muscle mass from lack of
protein you're gonna gain that weight
back in fat bottom line just stick to a
generally healthy well-balanced diet and
you won't you feel the need for any of
these crazy cleanses ABI
reduced fat foods are always better for
you dr. Sheffield on TV said so ah yes
the classic fat makes you fat idea is
still kicking around but when it comes
to commercially made food products it is
rarely as simple as just removing some
of the fat seem to keep some flavor in
there food manufacturers have to replace
that fat with things like sugar starch
additives salt and calories so if you
actually compare the nutrition labels of
a reduced fat product and a regular
counterpart you'll actually see there's
not a whole lot of difference in
calories the main difference is just
that one has more carbohydrates and the
other has more fat and believe it or not
even if there is a difference in
calories I usually recommend that people
go for the regular fat product if
they're watching their weight why one
fat is so much more satiating than sugar
if you're eating a low fat product that
is loaded up with sugar you're probably
gonna need a larger portion to feel
satisfied or you're just gonna have to
have a snack right after - for some
reason only see the words fat free or
reduced fat we think that gives us free
range to go crazy eat a whole bunch of
it those calories add up guys and 3 a
lot of those diet products they kind of
just taste like crap so if you're like
me you're probably feels so deprived
you're gonna know how to have a slice of
cheesecake afterwards bottom line
compare labels between reduced fat and
regular fat products making sure there's
actually a significant difference in
calories and they're not just loaded up
with sugar starch and additives so
that's it two more the most popular
nutrition myths busted do you have a
nutrition thing you want to bunk'd
subscribe to my channel leave me a
comment below or tweet me Abbey's
kitchen to have your burning nutrition
question answered in an upcoming video
thanks so much for watching I'll see you
next time on Abbey's kitchen happy
nutrition bone this month's theme is all
about eating well from 9 to 5 so today
I'm zoning in on commuter crave